with results still being counted some of
the most watched local races are still
too close to call this afternoon
and that includes the hotly contested
state senate district six
seat democratic senate majority leader
nicole cannizzaro now
leads republican april becker by just
900 or so votes
senate district five also very tight
this is with democrat christie watson
increasing her lead over republican
carrie ann buck the lead there just
about 173 votes
on the clark county commission district
c democrat ross miller has now doubled
his lead it's more than 500 votes over
current las vegas city council member
stavros anthony
that race has flip-flopped a couple of
times also very close
ballot question one a statewide measure
to remove the board of regents from the
nevada constitution
right now that measure is going down in
defeat 51 percent to 49
but again not called just yet eight news
now is your local election headquarters
you can find
updates on air on online on all these
races at 8newsnow.com